[Musique]
salut je m'appelle guillermo guiz je
suis belge mais je travaille ici en
france s'il ya un truc que j'ai jamais
vraiment compris dans votre pays c'est
autre concept de président de la
république
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça la
france avec 57% des voix jean pierre est
élu président de la république française
bon alors je sais ce que les français
vont me dire les français libres
oui mais on aurait dû monter un peu non
non on n'a aucune leçon à recevoir de la
part d'un royalistes qui bob virtuel
avec de la terre
bon vous me sortez oui c'est vrai né en
belgique on a un roi oui comme 11e c'est
intense pas quelqu'un qui est dévoré par
son ambition personnelle
voilà il n'a pas fait exprès des trois
no 3 no 3 se trouve son rêve c'était
d'être dantesque président
ça c'est un début de gingivite que fait
déjà commencé par brosser du haut vers
le bas ça c'est très bref pour toi jean
pierre rousselle et pourquoi votre
présent la république c'est un concept
bizarre moi je suis ravi que tu le
demandes du conseil de président de la
république il est bizarre pour trois
raisons premièrement légaux des
candidats à chaque élection
présidentielle et au moins leurs quinze
personnes qui se présentent ce qui veut
dire qu'en france il ya au moins 15
personnes qui se sentent tout à fait
capable de se retrouver à la tête d'un
pays
je suis l'homme qu'il faut pour la
france pas choquant climatique
pas de problème la crise économique
génère terrorisme avec plaisir le
chômage sans problème
oui on y va j'ai encore mangé un pneu
deuxièmement le dimanche de l'élection
aux éléments mobiles et pour la
présidentielle s'est carrément de compte
à rebours est le nouveau président de la
république m
[Applaudissements]
en belgique on met plus ou moins 500
jours a fait un gouvernement du coup le
compte à rebours c'est pas le même et le
nouveau premier ministre n'est pas
forcément ça prend un peu plus de temps
le jour où le premier ministre il entre
en fonction les belges ont tous oublié
qu'ils avaient une élection ça l'astuce
ou en france vous avez un autre apport
la patience aux attendu qu un bon café
ce bonjour ue pour les mains ce qui nous
en être à l'origine
troisièmement notre rapport au président
vous êtes tellement pressée d'avoir
quelqu'un de dimanche de l'élection
quand fait du jugement là c'est la cote
de popularité du président on est
désormais comme moi sont 19% qu'air
france est sur qu elle déclaré vouloir
qu'on me vole un organe monsieur comment
vous expliquez ça ben moi je pense votre
président en fait il a tellement de
pouvoir qu'un mot on dirait un peu un
roi je pense un peu quoi je vais
rebondir est environ un mois
mes chers compatriotes j'ai bien
réfléchi dans le contexte de crise
sanitaire qui est le nôtre je vous
autorise désormais à sortir de chez vous
le mardi entre 14h06 et 15h54 à cloche
pied en chantant petit mari de francis
cabrel
l activité préférée des français quand
ils ont un droit
[Applaudissements]
en fait votre délire en france c'est
choisir anar sous lequel vous allez
pouvoir pisser pendant cinq ans puis ce
qui est bien c'est qu'au bout de cinq
ans lydie que j'admire nouveau président
franchement on était quand même avec
jean-pierre l'ancien jean-pierre ben
ouais bon ça les regarde
[Musique]